no
[Applauso]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti ad una puntata di
cucina buttata è vero qualcuno di voi
dire anche l'amore non esiste io credo
che esista esiste anche quello per
sempre non credo nel matrimonio credo
solamente in un solo anello quello di
cipolla fritta oggi infatti fare una
roba che io ho sempre ordinato e basta
non ho mai fatto perché sarò sincero le
preparazioni con le pa stelle se
veramente sono sempre nude la merda dei
pastelli non sono proprio il nostro
forte specialmente il mio forte ma oggi
cercheremo di fare una ricetta quella di
giallozafferano di abbiamo rubato questa
ricetta ragazzi quindi bbb e vedremo se
effettivamente ci riuscirà come sempre
se ci riusciamo noi ci potete riuscire
anche voi per fare gli anelli di gq da
avremo bisogno dice vai a 100mila litri
di latte materno rubato bocca un pizzico
di cumulo un cucchiaio di olio
extravergine di uniti a un mezzo
cucchiaino di lievito pane angela il 90
grammi di farina infinito una sola cosa
vi chiedo però mentre il mio musica
tristissima sono due giorni che non
mangio
oggi che facciamo cina buttate la prima
volta che vuole finalmente potremo dirmi
e minuti però molto probabilmente di un
qualcosa che sarà estremamente nocivo
per il mio organismo del momento quello
preparato io se volete aiutarmi e
iscrivetevi ogni mattina aquilano si
sveglia e si chiede se qualcuno avrà
seguito la sua richiesta di iscriversi è
proprio facile avete presente lo stesso
pulsante con il quale solitamente
mettete di sly complicate su commenta e
scrivete stronzo
oppure cliccate sul video di un'altra
persona e comprovate il momento a
spingere quel mouse verso il bottone
iscriviti sd scrivete potete commentare
città
io saprò e magari il mattino
svegliandomi però forse non sono solo
perché tutti noi siamo un po soli ma io
più di voi va bene allora a questo punto
se non l'avete fatto
io sinceramente mi chiedo quando poi
qualcuno che chiedono soldi dai e 5 euro
che cazzo faccia e morite gratis tragga
è gratis
cioè gratis che riuscite a farlo da noi
tica mamma mia
la pasta è molto semplice buttate tutti
quanti gli ingredienti dentro una
ciotola e con una frusta arenate per
prima cosa aggiungiamo la farina dicono
di setacciarla giallozafferano va tutto
bene ma quando una cosa inconscia di
netta sgradevole io non la faccio
aggiungiamo il sale quanto basta
quanto basta non ho mai capito quanto
basta sinceramente non votato un po che
a quel punto mezza bustina di lievito
angela uniamo tutti quanti gli
ingredienti secchi
a quel punto aggiungiamo un uomo
chiedendo di conoscere
mammamia cocchieri annichiarico fa e non
è dettata dal nuovo di un uso dire come
funzionari usa stesso voce carlo v fu
come se lui non avesse messo conscio
dentro composto evasi casi fate silenzio
e non dite niente e se uno dei a guscio
poi dirà ecco cannes dezza di unione
quando poi tutto con gusto essere
entrato dentro festa non poter più
uscire
c'ero aggiungiamo il latte pubblica
ricca dovrebbe venire un composto
liquido una mascella
adesso già una frittata in uno è bravo
guarda poi quello che salta sul carro
dei vincitori
ok in questi lunghi mesi e non si
tolgono impazzisco
sono disperato piccolo mangerò questa mi
sembra ancora troppo di cui bisogna
aggiungere solo odio odio è il solo pd è
molto liquido non si attaccherà alla
cipolla
la soluzione giusta sia questa dicono di
far riposare per 30 minuti quindi magari
si creerà un tessuto che la renderà più
appiccicosa a fra poco a frappe passiamo
a questo punto alla tv dagli orchi anno
gli strati le cipolle anno gli strati
anche la mia pazienza degli strati molto
sottili molta attenzione dal talento
della cipolla farò molto catchy non
fatelo a casa così non posso affrontarlo
a questa cosa colleziona guarda ragazzi
è più difficile con sé non pensate voi
conficca realmente attento terzo spetta
non dovete avere un coltello molto
affilato per fare un cammino scivolosa
sia giusto o no non ho controllo mentre
invece così alta rientri poi s'è rotto
tutto tranne che anelli di cipolla
provando a tagliarle direttamente con la
buccia ma comodo mamma mia è l'unico
ripeto che fa piangere la cipollata una
giornata con te che possa far piangere
lo so la cucina come farebbe pure
piangere una cena preparata maria come
insalate di grazia ma fornisce un po di
chiodi perché li ho trovati
olio per friggere questa è la pastella
dopo mezz'ora non so cosa succederà
bravo bravo cavolo è davvero ragazzi sta
funzionando sentite che buon odore di
questa sembra la cintura è vero che
manca qualcosa
oddio gianmarco 30 è successo così a
prima vista è cosa si aspettasse
asciughi clima mite assaggio moltissimo
vedere c'era una cosa avete nelle cose
troppo poco
presentando nero troppo poco ora sono
più croccanti lasciali stare a farli
asciugare un secondo john ma con quel
dito posso darti cattive notizie sono
mobili mano che non sono l'iter fallito
e fallico protezione bello solo bello
livelli e dice gli anelli di cipolla ed
elastici per capelli grigi sono più
vicini perché sa più frittata c'è una
cosa carina mi stai dicendo che avevi
ragione tu ma come questo astio perché è
il padre gli anelli di cipolla anche
sono un fan degli edifici in realtà è ma
meno ma i ragazzi non vi fate ingannare
dall'aspetto questo è il classico
esempio dove la copertina è ingannevole
apriamo il ristorante colpi di gomma
cosa ho detto io le pa stelle non ne so
fare ho seguito tutto quanto cos'è che
avevo detto ci voleva più farina mitico
e ancora il risultato sono deluso ma in
realtà con più farina venivano posso
provare una cosa no si no cucina buttata
che cos'è una che si diventa tronto il
fallimento enrico gianmarco hanno finito
la loro giornata e quindi li dovete
andare a casa e non potete fare una
ricetta che funzioni davvero è questo
quello che siete aggiungono no di semola
i semola
questo comunque lei ci viene sempre meno
che c'è una farina di semola con la
farina mamma mi dovete lasciar lavorare
questo punto non sono guglielmo chiamati
vigili però posso dire che la
consistenza diversa effettivamente del
decreto ci ha messo la manina che
vediamo e densissima delusissimo
guardate la bellezza di questo non me le
manco fatto vedere che lei schiaffa con
la guarda la trave rilassati un live per
far rialzare enrico caruso capito
guardano intensamente e poi ok si bravo
bravissimo
se avevo ragione marco tudyk solo
chiedere scusa enrico ragazzi visto che
la cognata di grazzano è così brava con
la capa stelle ci sta dicendo nei venti
minuti chiamate chiara andate da trust a
nocera inferiore magna temi jonio rings
lo sai che sono belli non toccare ancora
mentre faccio andare gli ultimi onion
rings assaggerò quelli che ho fatto io
[Musica]
peggio enrico di ritrovarli e mezzo un
bozzetto grazia sono terribili
i ragazzi con la morte nel cuore che vi
saluto chiedo scusa per fatto sta creata
anche se non dovremmo chiedere scusa
abbiamo già abbiamo seguito una ricetta
non ha funzionato non è colpa mia ho
fatto di testa mia ancora peggio posso
dire ci hai messo il cuore e questo va
bene a cucina buttata li mette il gioco
frizzante operazione ci vediamo giovedì
con un nuovo video
[Musica]